Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. oracles prophecies apocalypse scientific projection we're always looking to the future can we tell what the future holds these are questions that have been really very pressing this year um coming up we have in in Glasgow, United Nations Climate Change Conference, focused on the question of where the entire planet is going, what the future of humanity is, whether the world is going to end. And of course, daily at the moment, we are trying to work out what the future of the pandemic is, when the lockdown will be able to end, whether we're going to get back to normality.
感谢收听《历史的余韵》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、无广告内容、抢先观看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。神谕、预言、世界末日、科学预测，我们总是展望未来，我们能预知未来吗？这些问题在今年变得非常紧迫。嗯，接下来在格拉斯哥将举行联合国气候变化大会，重点讨论整个地球的走向、人类的未来以及世界是否会终结。当然，目前我们每天都在努力弄清楚大流行的未来，封锁何时能够结束，我们是否会回到正常状态。
With me here is my co-conspirator, Dominic Sandbrook. Dominic, I guess that there is nothing new about looking to the future, is there? I mean, this is pretty much a constant, wanting to know what it holds. It's a sort of constant of human history, isn't it? So it's a slightly odd subject, isn't it, the history of the future? Because you think when you're a historian, you write purely about what happened in the past, but actually how people thought of the future is a really interesting topic. And obviously also, you know, it tells you an enormous amount about the context
和我在一起的是我的同谋多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。多米尼克，我想展望未来并不是什么新鲜事，对吧？我的意思是，这几乎是一种常态，人们总是想知道未来会怎样。这似乎是人类历史的一种常态，不是吗？所以“未来的历史”这个主题有点奇怪，对吧？因为你认为作为一名历史学家，你纯粹是写过去发生的事情，但实际上人们如何看待未来是一个非常有趣的话题。显然，这也让你对背景有了非常深刻的了解。
because generally when people were looking forward, they project their own anxieties, usually their own fears. And we've always done it, you know, the earliest religious texts, looking to the future, you know, people are fascinated now by what the world will be like, you know, is China going to rule the world? Are we going to all end up in a ball of flame? So it's actually a really interesting way to look back at the sort of imagination of the people who come before us i mean i do you think there's a kind of qualitative difference say between somebody looking um in chicken guts to work out what the future holds and the kind of
因为通常当人们展望未来时，他们会投射自己的焦虑，通常是他们自己的恐惧。我们一直都在这样做，你知道，最早的宗教文本就在展望未来。你知道，人们现在对世界会变成什么样很着迷，比如中国会统治世界吗？我们最终都会变成一团火球吗？所以，回顾我们之前的人们的想象力，这实际上是一种非常有趣的方式。我的意思是，你认为在通过观察鸡内脏来推断未来的人和那种……之间是否存在质的差异？
the the level uh at the beginning of the pandemic when basically we knew very little and it was clear that people knew very little but people still wanted answers and so people were broadcasting answers it kind of suggests almost that even if even if we don't know we would like to be told something about the future yes i think the sort of fog of uncertainty is often the most frightening thing of all isn't it and actually but in some ways we you know little knowledge is a dangerous thing if you know that you're just looking at a load of old guts, then at least you know where you stand. Whereas, you know, when you're sort of people are tweeting graphs and they've read, you know, they've spent the morning on Wikipedia. So they're an expert in epidemiology.
在大流行初期，基本上我们知之甚少，而且很明显人们也知之甚少，但人们仍然想要答案，所以人们在广播答案。这几乎表明，即使我们不知道，我们也希望被告知关于未来的一些事情。是的，我认为那种不确定性的迷雾往往是最可怕的事情，不是吗？实际上，在某些方面，你知道，一知半解是一件危险的事情。如果你知道你只是在看一堆旧内脏，那么至少你知道自己的立场。然而，当人们在推特上发布图表，并且他们已经花了一上午时间在维基百科上阅读时，他们就成了流行病学专家。
That, I think, can lead you down some pretty dark rabbit holes. Yeah, but I mean, the people look at look at you know people looking into the guts these were highly skilled definers they yes they thought that they knew what they were doing yeah and in a sense the guy on twitter with a graph i mean he kind of doing the same so i think the big difference is you know if you were living in i mean maybe medieval historians will say i'm talking nonsense but my sense is that if you were living in the sort of 12th century and you, when you look to the past, the past was sort of in the old king's reign or in King so-and-so's reign or something, you know, people will have wings or there will be cars or anything like that because society had been so stable for so long, effectively. But I think once you had the scientific revolution,
我认为这会把你带入一些非常黑暗的兔子洞。是的，但我的意思是，那些观察内脏的人，他们是技术高超的定义者，他们确实认为自己知道自己在做什么。在某种意义上，推特上那个拿着图表的家伙，他也在做同样的事情。所以我认为最大的区别在于，如果你生活在……也许中世纪历史学家会说我在胡说八道，但我的感觉是，如果你生活在12世纪左右，当你展望过去时，过去是在老国王的统治下，或者在某某国王的统治下，你知道，人们会有翅膀，或者会有汽车之类的东西，因为社会长期以来一直非常稳定。但我认为一旦有了科学革命，
then thoughts about change really began to sort of colour the way that people thought of the future. So they thought about it in terms of inventions and technology rather than necessarily the rise and fall of states or of dynasties or something don't you think that's a big a big shift well i i think that actually people in the middle ages did have a sense that the future might be very different and that's because it had been written for them in the bible and i know you will kind of moan at the thought that no no no i knew this was coming but i actually think that um the the idea that in a sense the future is written and that it has a definite end point is something that's quite
那么关于变革的想法就开始影响人们思考未来的方式。所以他们从发明和技术的角度来思考未来，而不一定是国家的兴衰或王朝的更替。你不觉得这是一个巨大的转变吗？嗯，我认为中世纪的人们确实有一种未来可能会非常不同的感觉，那是因为《圣经》已经为他们写好了。我知道你会因为想到这一点而抱怨，不不不，我知道这会发生，但我实际上认为……在某种意义上，未来是注定的，并且有一个明确的终点，这是非常独特的。
distinctive because actually most societies most time across most of the world have tended to assume that time time is circular so that uh know, there are orders of existence and then they end and then they begin again. And it just goes round and round. Yeah. But our civilization, Muslim civilization, both have this very strong idea that there's a point of creation and then there is a point a kind of end of days um and i think that that perhaps continues to structure the way that we think of the future to this day i mean the kind i and i don't know what the answer to this is whether in non-christian non-muslim civilizations whether there is quite the same kind of apocalyptic sense of anxiety about where climate change might lead i mean i'm
因为实际上，世界上大多数社会在大多数时间里往往认为时间是循环的，所以存在存在的秩序，然后它们结束，然后又重新开始。它只是周而复始。是的。但我们的文明和穆斯林文明都有这种非常强烈的观念，即有一个创造点，然后有一个世界末日。我认为这可能至今仍在构建我们思考未来的方式。我的意思是，我不知道这个问题的答案是什么，在非基督教和非穆斯林文明中，是否也存在同样关于气候变化可能导致什么的末日焦虑感？我的意思是，我
not denying that climate change is a monster threat but i think that we are culturally conditioned to expect that we sin and we will then be judged for our sins and the punishment will be visited on the entire world with terrible devastation and plagues and famines and things and i think that that is still kind of part of our our mental furniture we have a sense of the story being finite of the story having an end and if you think about i mean this is a strange example but the way the vikings thought about ragnarok so at the end of ragnarok the earth is then reborn and the sort of story starts again um that that's not what happens in in christian thinking is it or muslim thinking you know the earth dies and then that's it history comes to an end yes but again with
并不是否认气候变化是一个巨大的威胁，但我认为我们在文化上被设定为认为我们犯罪，然后我们将因我们的罪孽而受到审判，惩罚将降临到整个世界上，带来可怕的破坏、瘟疫和饥荒。我认为这仍然是我们精神结构的一部分。我们有一种故事是有限的、故事有终点的感觉。如果你想想……这是一个奇怪的例子，但维京人对“诸神黄昏”的看法，在“诸神黄昏”结束时，地球重生，故事又重新开始。这在基督教思想中不是这样，对吧？或者在穆斯林思想中，你知道，地球死亡，然后就结束了，历史走向终结。是的，但同样，对于
ragnarok it's difficult because we don't know the degree to which that vision of the end of the gods and the end of the world is kind of contaminated by christianity yeah yeah it's written down much later isn't it yeah so it's it's very difficult to tell but i do think that um that the kind of the the idea that time goes forward kind of you know the contrast is time's arrow against time's wheel and we definitely live in a time's arrow civilization and i'm sure that that then you know you talk about the the huge impact that technology has and technological development that that then fuses with that sense that um that you increasingly get with the industrial revolution that yeah the
“诸神黄昏”来说，这很困难，因为我们不知道那种关于众神终结和世界终结的愿景在多大程度上受到了基督教的污染。是的，它写得晚得多，不是吗？所以很难判断。但我确实认为，时间向前发展的观念……你知道，对比是时间之箭与时间之轮，我们绝对生活在一个时间之箭的文明中。我相信，你谈到的技术和技术发展的巨大影响，与工业革命带来的那种感觉融合在一起，即……
the future will just be qualitatively different but we can under you know we we can it's not a problem for us to kind of comprehend that because we're so you know civilizationally adjusted to the idea that time is going forward in a single continuous stream but it's sort of the idea of progress isn't it people um we live in a world where the idea of of sort of forward movement is hardwired into our sense of the of the world and actually i guess for people before well my feeling would be be that for people before about 1700, their sense of forward movement was purely a sort of almost a moral one or a theological one. So what's coming is going to be the sort of fifth monarchy and and we'll have, you know, flying horses and carriages or whatever. The expectations become much less morally freighted. I mean, I think that there are kind of moral reawakening.
未来在质量上会有所不同，但我们可以理解这一点，因为我们在文明上已经适应了时间在单一连续流中向前流动的观念。这是一种进步的观念，不是吗？人们……我们生活在一个向前运动的观念深深植根于我们世界观的世界里。实际上，我想对于1700年以前的人来说，他们对向前运动的感觉纯粹是一种道德或神学上的感觉。所以即将到来的是第五君主制，我们将有飞马和马车之类的东西。期望变得不再那么具有道德负担。我的意思是，我认为有一种道德上的觉醒。
The idea that Europe is being clothed with a veil of white churches coincides with the fact that people are conscious that, in a sense, life is kind of getting better. But I completely agree that it's the speed and pace of technological change that you get in the modern period that is really different and transformative. And so, I mean, do you think that the kind of scientific visions that we have now, which are often dystopias, how far back do they go, do you think? The sense of the future as being structured by technology and science i think that's really interesting because some of the the i mean a great prediction of the future come from 1733 so the sort of heart of the scientific
欧洲被白色教堂的面纱所覆盖的观念，与人们意识到生活在某种意义上正在变好的事实相吻合。但我完全同意，现代时期技术变革的速度和节奏确实是不同的，而且是变革性的。所以，我的意思是，你认为我们现在所拥有的那种科学愿景（通常是反乌托邦）可以追溯到多远？未来由技术和科学构建的观念，我认为这非常有趣，因为一些……我的意思是，对未来的伟大预测来自1733年，也就是科学革命的核心。
revolution is from a fellow called samuel madden who is an anglican clergyman, he wrote a book called Memoirs of the 20th Century, pretty much unreadable now and unread, actually. And even amidst all this change, and you know, the Industrial Revolution is really kicking off, he saw it purely in terms that would appeal to you. So he thought the world was going to have this great confrontation between the Jesuits and the deists. This was a kind of ideological conflict to the future and he was obsessed with the pope and you know the papal forces were were going to take over the world and all this kind of thing you kind of think how wrong can you be you know obviously because we know that the papal power was in you know deep decline um uh in the sort of early modern later early modern period um but you know that's a sign that it's
来自一位名叫塞缪尔·马登的圣公会牧师，他写了一本名为《20世纪回忆录》的书，现在几乎无法阅读，实际上也没人读。即使在所有这些变化中，你知道，工业革命真正开始的时候，他纯粹以一种会吸引你的方式来看待它。所以他认为世界将迎来耶稣会士和自然神论者之间的大对抗。这是一种对未来的意识形态冲突，他痴迷于教皇，你知道，教皇势力将接管世界等等。你会想，你错得有多离谱，你知道，显然因为我们知道教皇的权力在近代早期后期处于深度衰落中……但你知道，这是一个迹象，表明
not just about um technology often morality is a huge part of it so morality is there in kind of brave new world or does huxley's um vision of the future and this sort of sense that um so it's it's not so much the sort of technological accomplishments of science that are interesting but it's their effect on our behavior and on that sort of ethical you know conduct and all that sort of thing i think that's always a big always a huge part of it tom i i know this is slightly going off piste what's just been distracting me during my reply do you have a picture of ian botham just over your shoulder i do yes yes it was given to me but on for our wedding and it's a signed photograph of the great man giving us best wishes.
这不仅仅是关于技术，道德往往是其中很大的一部分。所以道德存在于赫胥黎的《美丽新世界》中，那种对未来的愿景，以及那种感觉……所以这与其说是科学的技术成就很有趣，不如说是它们对我们行为和那种道德操守的影响。我认为这始终是其中很大的一部分，汤姆。我知道这有点偏离主题了，刚才在我的回答中让我分心的是，你的肩膀上方有一张伊恩·博瑟姆的照片吗？是的，确实，这是别人送给我的，作为我们婚礼的礼物，这是一张伟大人物签名的照片，祝我们一切顺利。
We're going to have to cut this. No, no, no, I think the listeners will love this. I mean, it's so good that you absolutely conform to the expectations that people would have of you. I mean, they really would think that this is what's going on, and it is. Well, I have to say that when I got it for our wedding, if I looked into the future, I'd be very happy to know that um yeah it was being mentioned on a podcast which of course you know when i got married i had no idea what a podcast was yeah that's the thing okay which
我们得把这段剪掉。不，不，不，我想听众会喜欢这个的。我的意思是，你完全符合人们对你的期望，这太好了。我的意思是，他们真的会认为这就是正在发生的事情，事实也确实如此。好吧，我必须说，当我在婚礼上得到它时，如果我展望未来，我会很高兴知道……是的，它在播客中被提到了，当然，你知道，当我结婚时，我根本不知道什么是播客。是的，就是这样。好吧，这
brings us back yeah i that is going off piece but so let me again you know you're a historian of the modern period do you think that our understanding of the future and the way that it changes is speeding up? No, I don't think it's speeding up. I think there are obviously different phases. There are clearly, you know, different phases of our understanding of the future. So at the turn of the 20th century, when people thought about the future, they thought about it in terms of state conflict, actually, didn't they? It was all invasion stories and scare stories about world wars.
把我们带回了……是的，这确实偏离了主题，但让我再问一次，你是现代史学家，你认为我们对未来的理解以及它的变化方式正在加速吗？不，我不认为它在加速。我认为显然有不同的阶段。我们对未来的理解显然有不同的阶段。所以在20世纪之交，当人们思考未来时，他们是从国家冲突的角度来思考的，不是吗？全是入侵故事和关于世界大战的恐慌故事。
And then the visions that people had of the future in the sort of mid 20th century, the really sort of influential ones like 1984, they're about totalitarianism and political ideology. And the ones we've had since that, roughly, I mean, there was obviously the expectations of war three um in the 70s and 80s but that was a massive tradition wasn't it i mean that was gone now hasn't it you don't see it at all now i mean yeah i mean remember that book um we were talking about it before we started uh the third world war by general sir john hackett yes white they wipe out birmingham yeah they drop a nuclear bomb on Birmingham, the Russians. And there was all that stuff, Threads, the war game, all these terrifying visions of nuclear apocalypse. But actually what we've had since then,
然后是20世纪中期人们对未来的愿景，那些真正有影响力的，比如《1984》，它们是关于极权主义和政治意识形态的。从那以后我们所拥有的那些，大致上……我的意思是，70年代和80年代显然有对第三次世界大战的预期，但那是一个巨大的传统，不是吗？我的意思是，现在已经消失了，不是吗？你现在根本看不到了。我的意思是，是的，记得我们开始前谈论的那本书吗？约翰·哈克特将军的《第三次世界大战》，是的，他们消灭了伯明翰，是的，俄罗斯人向伯明翰投下了一枚核弹。还有所有那些东西，《线索》、《战争游戏》，所有这些关于核末日的恐怖愿景。但实际上，从那以后我们所拥有的，
I mean, they're almost always about two things. They're either about computers and sort of virtual worlds, so the sort of Neuroman ish or blade runner i suppose which about robots or they're about um environmental catastrophe and that's our big i mean that's our book of revelation isn't it that's our obsession that is i i think yes as to say i think i think climate change definitely is is absolutely running with that i mean, I wrote a book about the year 1000, which, for all kinds of obvious reasons, was apocalyptic anxieties, I think, is debated, but I think it's pretty clear that they were very much part of the climate of the time.
我的意思是，它们几乎总是关于两件事。它们要么是关于计算机和虚拟世界，比如《神经漫游者》或《银翼杀手》，关于机器人；要么是关于环境灾难，这就是我们的《启示录》，不是吗？这就是我们的痴迷。我认为是的，我想说，我认为气候变化绝对是与此相关的。我的意思是，我写了一本关于公元1000年的书，出于所有显而易见的原因，末日焦虑，我认为是有争议的，但我认为很明显，它们确实是当时气候的一部分。
And there are all these kind of anxieties and terrors and dread. And while I was writing that, I read James Lovelock, who wrote a particularly terrifying kind of jeremiad about what was going to happen. And essentially saying that, you know, the world would be uninhabitable by 2030. And the language that he was using was eerily reminiscent. Plagues, famines. And for us in. I mean, that's I think is the crucial thing. Whereas I agree that in a sense, the computers and online particularly is something that would be absolutely unimaginable to i mean even even to someone in 1970 i guess yeah well maybe philip k dick who i have a shame to say
还有所有这些焦虑、恐惧和忧虑。在写那本书的时候，我读了詹姆斯·洛夫洛克，他写了一篇特别可怕的关于将要发生什么的哀歌。本质上是说，你知道，到2030年世界将变得不适合居住。他使用的语言令人毛骨悚然地让人想起瘟疫、饥荒。对于我们来说……我的意思是，我认为这是关键所在。虽然我同意在某种意义上，计算机和在线特别是一些对1970年的人来说绝对无法想象的事情，我想是的。好吧，也许菲利普·K·迪克，我很惭愧地说
i've never read but i mean he kind of when's he writing 50s is he yeah i mean he's kind of starting to to pick up on that but it's uh you know william gibson and and people like that are kind of just ahead of the curve and and now um you know it's all about computers yeah it's interesting isn't it because i mean i've written as you know these sort of books about post-war britain and and the computers and technology are always there in the background right from the beginning so my book starts in the early 50s mid-50s and in 1955 the daily mirror did a big um huge series um called the robot revolution about how you know robots as they called them were going to change the world and the expectation for a long time was that computers would just would make everything so
我从来没读过，但我的意思是，他是在50年代写的，是吗？是的，我的意思是，他开始注意到这一点，但这是……你知道，威廉·吉布森和像那样的人只是走在了时代的前面。现在，你知道，一切都是关于计算机的。是的，这很有趣，不是吗？因为我的意思是，正如你所知，我写过这些关于战后英国的书，计算机和技术从一开始就一直存在于背景中。所以我的书从50年代初、50年代中期开始，在1955年，《每日镜报》做了一个巨大的系列报道，名为《机器人革命》，关于他们所说的机器人将如何改变世界。长期以来的预期是，计算机将使一切变得如此
great and you just have so much leisure um and jetpacks yeah well obviously you've got the 60s sort of utopianism i mean that has completely been lost and you saw that everywhere in the 60s in in fashion and design in the in the design of cities you know the sort of local busier look that became very popular in the 60s um and then in the 70s that died and you had i mean obviously star wars's vision of the i mean i know it's a long long time ago but this vision of the future is a bit dirtier um than 2001s and then you have blade runner which is obviously an adaptation of philip k dick where it's all driving rain and misery and
美好，你会有很多闲暇时间，还有喷气背包。是的，好吧，显然你有60年代的那种乌托邦主义，我的意思是，那已经完全消失了。你在60年代的时尚和设计中随处可见，在城市的设计中，你知道，60年代变得非常流行的那种局部繁忙的外观……然后到了70年代，那消失了，你有了……我的意思是，显然《星球大战》对……的愿景，我的意思是，我知道那是很久很久以前的事了，但这个未来的愿景比《2001太空漫游》要脏一点。然后你有《银翼杀手》，显然是菲利普·K·迪克的改编版，到处都是倾盆大雨、苦难和
pollution and and and you know this sort of this sort of pure dystopia and that and we've remained there ever since and if anything when we talked about the road i think in a cormac mccarthy's um book in a previous podcast you know that's become that sort of vision has now become all enveloping you never see an optimistic prediction of the future now it's all about either a withdrawal into technological escapism because your jobs have been destroyed by computers and robots or it's you know just sort of living in a apocalyptic wasteland uh because your your and your climate has been completely ravaged but i wonder going back to the book of revelation whether that's simply because it's it's kind of easier and more fun in a way to portray a disaster
污染，你知道，这种纯粹的反乌托邦。从那以后我们就一直停留在那里。如果说有什么不同的话，当我们谈到科马克·麦卡锡的书《路》时，在之前的播客中，你知道，那种愿景现在已经变得无处不在。你现在再也看不到对未来的乐观预测了。一切要么是退缩到技术逃避主义中，因为你的工作被计算机和机器人摧毁了；要么是……你知道，只是生活在末日的荒原中，因为你的气候已经被彻底蹂躏了。但我怀疑，回到《启示录》，这是否仅仅是因为描绘灾难在某种程度上更容易、更有趣
than it is yeah so you've got, you know, the horsemen of the apocalypse and plagues and everything. And then you've got, you know, quite short passage about how great it's going to be when the New Jerusalem descends. But then it ends. It's actually very hard to describe what the New Jerusalem is going to be. Yes. Quite boring.
而不是……是的，所以你有天启四骑士、瘟疫等等。然后你有一段很短的关于新耶路撒冷降临时会有多美好的段落。但随后它就结束了。描述新耶路撒冷将是什么样子实际上非常困难。是的。相当无聊。
That's basically like Marxism, isn't it? I mean, it spends a lot of time talking about the struggles to bring, you know, the new world. But then the new world itself is never actually described because who cares? You know, it's just looking at pot plants and strolling in country walks. And that's not very interesting. Right. Well, Dominic, I'm going to give a prophecy. And the prophecy is we're going to go for a break in a minute.
这基本上就像马克思主义，不是吗？我的意思是，它花了很多时间谈论为带来新世界而进行的斗争。但新世界本身从未被真正描述过，因为谁在乎呢？你知道，它只是看着盆栽植物，在乡村散步。那不是很有趣。好吧，多米尼克，我要做一个预言。预言就是我们马上要休息一下。
And when we come back, we're going to look at people's uh questions and try and answer them so that's my prophecy let's see if it comes true i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Two episodes again this week. On Thursday, we will be discussing our top 10 weird wars. We've
当我们回来时，我们将看看人们的问题并尝试回答它们，这就是我的预言，让我们看看它是否会成真。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的余韵》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先购买现场票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余韵》。本周又是两集。周四，我们将讨论我们心目中十大怪异战争。我们
got some fantastically bizarre ones lined up to discuss. But for now, let's move on to your questions. Dominic, do we have any questions? We do, Tom. This first one is an absolute gift for you. So it's from Joel Coppersmith. And he says, did the ancients believe in the Delphic Oracle? Now, just before you answer that, I will just say this. In Assassin's Creed Odyssey, you find out that the woman who is the Oracle is actually... The Pythia. She's working for the cult of Cosmos, who are the villains,
准备了一些非常离奇的战争来讨论。但现在，让我们进入你们的问题。多米尼克，我们有任何问题吗？有的，汤姆。第一个问题对你来说绝对是一份礼物。它来自乔尔·科珀史密斯。他说，古人相信德尔斐神谕吗？现在，在你回答之前，我只想说这一点。在《刺客信条：奥德赛》中，你发现那个作为神谕的女人实际上是……皮提亚。她为邪恶的“秩序神教”工作，
and she knows she's giving false prophecies. So that's my answer. Oh, really? Yeah. You've steered clear of this, haven't you? Because you think you'll be addicted but um yes for the same reason i haven't taken up heroin i'm sure it's great but it kind of has bad bad side effects since i have a nine-year-old in the house we we haven't
她知道自己在给出虚假的预言。所以这就是我的答案。哦，真的吗？是的。你一直避开这个，对吧？因为你认为你会上瘾，但……是的，出于同样的原因，我没有尝试过海洛因，我相信它很棒，但它有一些糟糕的副作用。因为我家里有一个九岁的孩子，我们……我们没有……
yes absolutely the uh the greeks of course because otherwise they wouldn't have gone and consulted it otherwise it would have been a kind of wasted effort but um what's distinctive i think about the uh the way that the greeks view their oracles and perhaps apollo's oracle specifically is that they expect it to be tricksy they they expect it to be elliptical so um Herodotus in his great work, translated by me, describes how the Ethiopians, when they consult the oracle, they will get an answer and they will do exactly what the oracle tells them. And Herodotus obviously sees this as being kind of slightly unusual and odd. And the reason that he sees it odd is that it's taken for granted by the Greeks that Apollo's answers will be hard to understand. So he's called Loxias, which essentially means the oblique one. And again and again,
是的，绝对是……希腊人当然相信，否则他们就不会去咨询它，否则那将是一种浪费。但……我认为关于希腊人看待神谕的方式，也许特别是阿波罗的神谕，独特之处在于他们期望它是狡猾的，他们期望它是晦涩的。所以……希罗多德在他伟大的著作中（由我翻译）描述了埃塞俄比亚人在咨询神谕时，他们会得到一个答案，然后他们会完全按照神谕告诉他们的去做。希罗多德显然认为这有点不寻常和奇怪。他认为这很奇怪的原因是，希腊人理所当然地认为阿波罗的回答很难理解。所以他被称为“洛克西亚斯”（Loxias），本质上意味着“晦涩者”。一次又一次，
the famous example is Croesus, the king of Lydia, who is preparing to go to war with Cyrus, king of the Persians, who's very much the rising power, not sure whether he should launch a preemptive attack. So goes to Delphi rather in the way that a government now might go to a kind of think tank or perhaps a spy agency or something and says you know should i attack the persians and the delphic oracle replies um if you cross uh the river that marks the frontier between you and cyrus's kingdom um a great empire will fall and croesus assumes that this means that it's cyrus's empire that will fall but course, it's Croesus's empire that falls. And the genius of that is, of course, that it's an unfalsifiable argument because one of the two empires is going to fall.
著名的例子是吕底亚国王克罗伊索斯，他正准备与波斯国王居鲁士开战，居鲁士是正在崛起的强权，他不确定是否应该发动先发制人的攻击。所以他去德尔斐，就像现在的政府可能会去智库或间谍机构一样，说，你知道，我应该攻击波斯人吗？德尔斐神谕回答说……如果你越过标志着你和居鲁士王国边界的河流……一个伟大的帝国将会灭亡。克罗伊索斯认为这意味着将要灭亡的是居鲁士的帝国，但当然，灭亡的是克罗伊索斯的帝国。而这其中的天才之处在于，它是一个不可证伪的论点，因为两个帝国中总有一个会灭亡。
But that happened all the time, didn't it? I mean, so Philip of Macedon, when he was about to launch his attack on Persia, he went to the Oracle of Delphi and he got this message that said, wreathed is the bull, the hour is near or something, the one who will kill him is at hand. And he thought, great, I'm going to kill the King of Persia and become ruler of the world. And then he died about, he was killed himself, assassinated, you know, a couple of months later. So this was
但这经常发生，不是吗？我的意思是，马其顿的腓力在准备发动对波斯的攻击时，他去了德尔斐神谕，他收到的信息说，公牛戴着花环，时刻临近了，或者类似的话，那个将要杀死他的人就在附近。他想，太好了，我要杀死波斯国王并成为世界统治者。然后他死了……他自己被暗杀了，你知道，几个月后。所以这
obviously a theme of consulting the Delphic Oracle. You think, you know, basically you end up being stabbed in the back by your own prophecy. I think the art was either to give, rather like Nostradamus, who I'm sure we'll come on to later, to frame things in such a way that they're sufficiently vague that you can kind of pattern events, you know, whatever happens. I think on top of that, there is a degree to which the priests at Delphi are, they're the only professional priesthood that the Greeks have. And people are coming from across not just the Greek world, but beyond the Greek world as well, and therefore bringing information with them. And so the priests, to that extent, are probably the best informed people in Greece about what is going on internationally. And so that gives them perhaps a kind of broader perspective on events than anyone
显然是咨询德尔斐神谕的一个主题。你认为，你知道，基本上你最终会被你自己的预言从背后捅一刀。我认为艺术要么是给出……就像诺查丹玛斯（我肯定我们稍后会谈到），以一种足够模糊的方式来构建事物，这样你就可以在任何事情发生时将其与模式联系起来。我认为除此之外，德尔斐的祭司在某种程度上是希腊人拥有的唯一的专业祭司阶层。人们不仅从希腊世界，而且从希腊世界之外来到这里，因此随身携带信息。因此，在某种程度上，祭司可能是希腊最了解国际局势的人。这也许给了他们一种比其他人更广阔的事件视角。
else has. So that's maybe something that they can feed into their prophecies. I think also, there's a famous example, when the Persians invade Greece in 480 and the odds look overwhelming and the Athenians go to Delphi and say, you know, what's going to happen? And the first oracle is basically run for your lives. You're going to get crushed. You have no hope. Athens is going to burn. And the Athenians are devastated. And then a priest comes out and says, well, go and ask again. So they go in and they get a famous second prophecy where the Athenians are told that, yeah, Athens is going to burn, I'm afraid. There's no way around that. But the wooden wall will hold. And then it kind of ends with a reference to Salamis, the island of Salamis. And sure enough, Athens does burn. The wooden wall, i.e. the Greek fleet, the Athenian fleet, does hold. And this battle is fought at Salamis.
所以这也许是他们可以融入预言的东西。我认为还有，有一个著名的例子，当波斯人在公元前480年入侵希腊时，胜算看起来微乎其微，雅典人去德尔斐说，你知道，会发生什么？第一个神谕基本上是逃命吧。你们会被碾碎。你们没有希望。雅典会被烧毁。雅典人崩溃了。然后一个祭司出来说，好吧，再去问一次。所以他们进去，得到了著名的第二个预言，雅典人被告知，是的，雅典会被烧毁，恐怕是这样。这是无法避免的。但木墙会守住。然后它以对萨拉米斯（萨拉米斯岛）的引用结束。果然，雅典确实被烧毁了。木墙，即希腊舰队，雅典舰队，确实守住了。这场战役是在萨拉米斯进行的。
And it's pretty clear. I think, I mean, I think that this oracle is an authentic one. I don't think it's a back projection. And so in a way, it's the most, you know, it's the most impressive oracle that we get. I mean, it's, you know, but I think that the Delphic priests, if they were thinking of a way in which the Greeks could survive, they would be aware that the Athenian strategy was to abandon Athens, to take to their fleet. And if there was going to be a naval battle that the Greeks were going to win, it was going to be by the Greeks luring the Persians into the Straits of Salamis. That was their only chance of victory. So I think there, again, you can see that they're kind of taking a punt. So they're delivering one oracle that says you're doomed, and then they're
这很清楚。我认为，我的意思是，我认为这个神谕是真实的。我不认为它是事后投射。所以从某种意义上说，这是我们得到的最令人印象深刻的神谕。我的意思是，它是……你知道，但我认为德尔斐的祭司，如果他们想出一种希腊人可以生存的方式，他们会意识到雅典的战略是放弃雅典，转向他们的舰队。如果有一场希腊人会赢的海战，那将是希腊人诱使波斯人进入萨拉米斯海峡。那是他们获胜的唯一机会。所以我认为在那里，你再次可以看到他们是在赌博。所以他们给出了一个说你们注定要失败的神谕，然后他们
delivering another one which gives up the only chance the Greeks had a victory. So I think that's kind of how it works. But I'm sure that, you know, I mean, of course people believed it, because otherwise you wouldn't go and consult it. Just one last thought on oracles before we move on to the other questions. They were pretty weird, weren't they? So I think I'm right in saying the oracle at the Temple of Ammon in Siwa um when you went and consulted that the oracle was this big stone that was on a sort of tray that the priests held above their heads and you asked it questions on a piece of paper and and the priests put answers on other bits of paper on the floor and then they sort of shuffled around as the stone directed them towards the piece of paper that had the appropriate answer have you heard this story
给出了另一个提供了希腊人获胜唯一机会的神谕。所以我认为这就是它的运作方式。但我肯定，你知道，我的意思是，当然人们相信它，因为否则你就不会去咨询它。在转向其他问题之前，关于神谕的最后一个想法。它们很奇怪，不是吗？所以我认为我说得对，锡瓦阿蒙神庙的神谕……当你去咨询那个神谕时，神谕是一块放在祭司举在头顶的托盘上的大石头，你在纸上问它问题，祭司把答案放在地板上的其他纸片上，然后他们随着石头引导他们走向有合适答案的纸片而四处走动。你听说过这个故事吗？
well i think that um one of the key things in in antiquity is that just having a bloke who who gives answers was seen as being too easy unreliable so so at delphi it's fumes coming up at sea where you have um as you've described uh at dodona in northern greece it's the rustling of um the sacred oak the leaves so essentially it's it's all about um interpretation yeah so that you so so that you can give the answer that that you think is is likeliest to come true and in many cases what the person who's coming wants to hear. But people never come and ask for their money back or they never come and say you told me to plough this field or to marry so and so or whatever
好吧，我认为……古代的关键点之一是，仅仅有一个给出答案的家伙被认为太容易、不可靠。所以在德尔斐，有冒出来的烟雾；在锡瓦，你有你描述的那样；在希腊北部的多多纳，是神圣橡树叶子的沙沙声。所以本质上，这一切都是关于解释，这样你就可以给出你认为最有可能成真的答案，在许多情况下，是咨询者想听到的答案。但人们从来不会回来要求退款，或者他们从来不会说你告诉我耕这块地或娶某某人，或者其他什么，
and they're burning with rage. There's always a way that you can show that the God came to you. Well, because Croesus complains to Apollo and says, you know, you shafted me here. And Apollo comes and rescues him from being burnt alive on a pyre and says, well, actually, you know, I told you, right, you didn't interpret correctly. And anyway, because you were so good to me, I managed to give you a few years extra because necessity doomed you.
然后他们怒火中烧。总有一种方法可以证明神确实降临到了你身上。好吧，因为克罗伊索斯向阿波罗抱怨说，你知道，你在这里坑了我。阿波罗过来把他从火刑柱上救了下来，说，好吧，实际上，你知道，我告诉过你，对吧，你没有正确解释。而且无论如何，因为你对我很好，我设法给了你几年额外的时间，因为必然性注定了你的命运。
But I managed to get you a few years extra ruling as king before you got toppled. So stop moaning. And Croesus accepts the justice of what Apollo says. And that's him. That's him schooled. Do we have another? Yes, let's whiz on a bit because we've done Apocalypse. We've done oracles joey
但我设法让你在被推翻之前多做了几年国王。所以别抱怨了。克罗伊索斯接受了阿波罗所说的正义性。这就是他受到的教训。我们还有另一个吗？是的，让我们快点，因为我们已经讨论了末日。我们已经讨论了神谕。乔伊·
mccarthy um wants to know what you think of nostradamus he says hit the great fire of london nagasaki jfk he's been on the money every time are you a nostradamus fan tom uh well obviously when i was about 12 i read them obsessively and it was full of prophecies about i think the third world war happening in 1999 wasn't it there was a kind of um the great god of fire will descend from the sky so i was pretty terrified by that but it didn't happen and i think that nostradamus's prophecies are um exactly like the delphic ones but yeah they're incredibly they're laughably vague aren't they i mean i used to live in nostradamus' hometown in Salon de Provence in the south of France. Yeah, I spent a year as a language assistant.
麦卡锡想知道你对诺查丹玛斯的看法。他说伦敦大火、长崎、肯尼迪，他每次都说中了。你是诺查丹玛斯的粉丝吗，汤姆？嗯，显然当我大约12岁的时候，我痴迷地读过它们，里面充满了关于我认为1999年发生第三次世界大战的预言，不是吗？有一种……伟大的火神将从天而降，所以我对此感到非常害怕，但它没有发生。我认为诺查丹玛斯的预言……和德尔斐的预言完全一样，但它们非常、可笑地模糊，不是吗？我的意思是，我曾经住在诺查丹玛斯的家乡，法国南部的普罗旺斯萨隆。是的，我做了一年的语言助理。
And, you know, they had a terrible waxwork museum of Nostradamus, which I went round one rainy afternoon. I was the only person and felt, I just felt displeased with the way my life had turned out, that this was how I was at the age of 21, spending my time. Anyway, that's by the by. As I remember, there was one prophecy that he gave.
而且，你知道，他们有一个可怕的诺查丹玛斯蜡像馆，我在一个下雨的下午逛了一圈。我是唯一的人，我感到对自己生活的结果感到不满，这就是我21岁时的样子，把时间花在这里。总之，那是题外话。我记得，他给出了一个预言。
Wasn't it about the death of Henry II in a joust? And the lance goes through his visor and kills him. And Nostradamus had apparently prophesied this. He got that right so that established his reputation but it's a bit like um there's another one a tweet by tom from 2019 um about mother shipton who back in the first half of the 16th century literally prophesied the internet around the world men's thoughts will fly quick as the twinkling of an eye that's not that's not literally the prediction.
是不是关于亨利二世在比武中死亡？长矛穿过他的面罩杀死了他。诺查丹玛斯显然预言了这一点。他做对了，所以这确立了他的声誉，但这有点像……还有另一个，汤姆2019年的推文，关于16世纪上半叶的莫瑟·希普顿，她字面上预言了互联网，全世界人们的思想将像眨眼一样飞快。那不是……那不是字面上的预测。
Are you a fan of Mothership, Tim? Are you familiar with her oeuvre? Has she got a cave somewhere? Is that where I got that right? She's got a cave in Knaresborough. I know because I did a radio programme about it. I think I've been to that cave. Yeah.
你是莫瑟·希普顿的粉丝吗，蒂姆？你熟悉她的作品吗？她在某个地方有个洞穴吗？我是在那里做对的吗？她在纳尔斯伯勒有一个洞穴。我知道，因为我做过一个关于它的广播节目。我想我去过那个洞穴。是的。
Well, yes, it turns things to stone. So it's quite an eerie and atmospheric place. It's one of Britain's oldest tourist attractions. But predictably, she seems to have lived in the early 16th century. The earliest mention to her prophecies comes up in the 1640s. So you can see why people might start to be interested in it around that time um when the when the great fire of london happens peeps says that he has overheard people saying that mother shipton had prophesied that it was going to happen so she's clearly kind of big news in in the um in the 17th century and i guess it's a bit like you know a graph on twitter it's amid the chaos of the times people grasping after mother shipton's
好吧，是的，它把东西变成了石头。所以这是一个非常阴森和有气氛的地方。它是英国最古老的旅游景点之一。但可以预见的是，她似乎生活在16世纪初。关于她预言的最早提及出现在1640年代。所以你可以看出为什么人们在那时开始对它感兴趣……当伦敦大火发生时，佩皮斯说他听到人们说莫瑟·希普顿预言了它会发生。所以她在17世纪显然是个大新闻。我猜这有点像，你知道，推特上的图表，在混乱的时代，人们抓住莫瑟·希普顿的
prophecy to explain what's happened. But the one about the men's thoughts were fly quick as the twinkling of an eye. There's another brilliant one, which is even better, which prophesies feminism. For in those wondrous far-off days, the women shall adopt a craze
预言来解释发生了什么。但关于“人们的思想将像眨眼一样飞快”的那一个。还有另一个精彩的，甚至更好，它预言了女权主义。因为在那些奇妙的遥远日子里，妇女们将采取一种狂热，
to dress like men and trousers wear and cut off their locks of hair. My word. I think you'd agree, Dominic, is, I mean, it's spooky, isn't it? It's the 1970s. Yeah, incredible. And then an even better one. The world to an end shall come in 1881.
像男人一样穿衣，穿裤子，剪掉她们的头发。天哪。我想你会同意，多米尼克，我的意思是，这很诡异，不是吗？这是1970年代。是的，不可思议。然后是一个更好的。世界将在1881年终结。
Okay, that's not literally true. That's not so good. But all of these were written by a guy in the mid-19th century. Were they? They're falsified. Oh, how depressing. They're completely falsified. Yeah. So all those ones are completely bogus.
好吧，那不是字面上的事实。那没那么好。但所有这些都是19世纪中期的一个家伙写的。是吗？它们是伪造的。哦，多令人沮丧。它们完全是伪造的。是的。所以所有那些都是完全虚假的。
All right, let's do Tom Watts. Tom Watts says he wants to know who was right orwell huxley or both is 1984 still to come is it here already do you have an answer to that tom i don't really uh you're you know that's much more your field uh so i think um well all well went slightly out of fashion at the end of the cold war because obviously he had been writing about you know basically a thinly veiled portrait of the Soviet Union. But now Orwell has sort of come back again with all the double think kind of talk and the sort of fascination with controlling language and controlling thought crime.
好吧，让我们谈谈汤姆·瓦茨。汤姆·瓦茨说他想知道谁是对的，奥威尔、赫胥黎还是两者都是？《1984》还在未来吗？它已经在这里了吗？你对此有答案吗，汤姆？我真的没有……你知道，那是你的领域……所以我认为……好吧，奥威尔在冷战结束时稍微过时了，因为显然他写的是……基本上是苏联的薄纱肖像。但现在奥威尔又回来了，带着所有的“双重思想”谈话，以及对控制语言和控制思想犯罪的迷恋。
So in that sense, Orwell was, you could argue, pretty prescient. He also has the TVs that watch you and listen to you, which, you know, if you've got an Alexa, it's a little bit worrying actually it's more all about biology isn't it it's years since i read brave new world i don't really remember that much about it but isn't it it's also about people kind of being blissed out and therefore not worrying about stuff yeah it's assassin's creed you know if you're playing assassin's creed you don't need to worry about well but that's not really true though is it because of course people you know we are we do live long comfortable lives and we just spend our time you know getting very frenzied and angry and
所以从这个意义上说，奥威尔，你可以说，非常有先见之明。他还有监视你和监听你的电视，你知道，如果你有Alexa，这实际上有点令人担忧。这更多是关于生物学，不是吗？我读《美丽新世界》已经很多年了，我不记得太多了，但它不是也关于人们处于极乐状态，因此不担心事情吗？是的，它是《刺客信条》，你知道，如果你在玩《刺客信条》，你不需要担心……好吧，但这并不是真的，对吧？因为当然人们……你知道，我们确实过着长寿舒适的生活，我们只是花时间，你知道，变得非常狂热和愤怒，以及
slacking each other off on twitter so yeah i mean people don't strike me as tremendously blissed out do you think the world is best out i don't do you Do you think, I mean, do you think on the, in 1984, the three divisions of the world? Oh, East Asia. And does it, you know, if the European Union, China and Britain as a kind of unsinkable aircraft carrier for America. Yeah, that's a good one. Maybe, so maybe that's where we're heading. Maybe.
在推特上互相挖苦，所以是的，我的意思是人们给我的印象并不是特别快乐。你认为世界是快乐的吗？我不觉得，你呢？你认为，我是说，你认为在1984年，世界的三大分区？哦，东亚。而且，你知道，如果欧盟、中国和英国作为美国的一种永不沉没的航空母舰。是的，那是个好比喻。也许，所以也许这就是我们前进的方向。也许吧。
I don't know. Yes, who knows. I don't know. Here's a good one from Ollie Simpson. In the end, Halley's Comet was an omen for a big event in 1066. So that's the appearance of Halley's Comet featured in the Bay of Tapestry, prophesying the tumultuous year to come. To what extent did it actually influence events,
我不知道。是的，谁知道呢。我不知道。这里有一个来自奥利·辛普森的好问题。最终，哈雷彗星是1066年重大事件的预兆。所以哈雷彗星的出现出现在贝叶挂毯上，预示着动荡的一年即将到来。它在多大程度上真正影响了事件，
and are there other examples of this happening so um i'm sure that that what what happened in 1066 would have happened whether halley's comet happened or not but are there examples of um natural phenomena impacting the way that people understand the world um maybe a question more for me than you. That's maybe unfair for you. Well, you're clearly asking it to yourself. No, I wasn't. I honestly wasn't. Unusually, I wasn't. You forgot that there was somebody else there.
还有其他类似的例子吗？嗯，我肯定1066年发生的事情无论哈雷彗星是否出现都会发生，但有没有自然现象影响人们理解世界方式的例子？嗯，这可能更像是一个问我的问题，而不是问你。这对你来说可能不公平。好吧，你显然是在问你自己。不，我不是。我真的不是。不同寻常的是，我真的不是。你忘了还有别人在场。
I think the 6th century in the Mediterranean is an example because that was a time of uh extraordinary celestial phenomena uh a darkening of the skies um terrible climactic events and that had a knock-on effect in terms of global cooling um which in turn i think definitely had a knock-on effect in fostering apocalyptic expectation um and i'm sure that what becomes Islam initially begins as a kind of apocalyptic attempt to prepare the world for the wrath of God to appease his anger. So I think that that would be probably my answer, that the kind of reverberations from that. Yeah, these things do reverberate, don't they? So the 17th century, which we talked about, I mean, the Little Ice yeah and the sort of global cooling and the famines and the rain and and all that that that clearly did encourage people's sense of the the apocalyptic and the coming of christ these are
我认为地中海的6世纪就是一个例子，因为那是一个有着非凡天象的时期，天空变暗，可怕的气候事件，这在导致全球变冷方面产生了连锁反应，而这反过来，我认为绝对在培养末日预期方面产生了连锁反应。而且我肯定，最初成为伊斯兰教的东西，开始时是一种试图为上帝的愤怒准备世界以平息他愤怒的末日尝试。所以我认为这可能就是我的答案，那种来自那里的回响。是的，这些事情确实会产生回响，不是吗？所以17世纪，我们谈论过的，我的意思是，小冰河期，以及那种全球变冷、饥荒、降雨等等，这些显然确实鼓励了人们对末日和基督降临的感觉，这些是
the end times i mean you do think that when the world that's what we think people think now i mean that yes i mean that's yes exactly what people think now yes yes and we're being punished for our sins yeah so i can't believe you you missed this question because this is an absolute i mean you probably wrote this yourself chet archbold if he if he exists it was just your sock puppet he what he's got he he or you have written a question about the sibylline books um it was not me so the sibylline books are roman and they're these well tell us what the sibiline books are uh so the sibiline books are what i begin rubicon with uh my book about the fall of the roman republic so yes perhaps it was me who knows um uh the sibiline books were um supposedly so the
末日，我的意思是，你确实认为当世界……这就是我们现在的想法，人们现在的想法，是的，我的意思是，是的，这正是人们现在的想法，是的，是的，我们因为我们的罪孽而受到惩罚。是的，所以我不敢相信你错过了这个问题，因为这绝对是……我的意思是，你可能自己写了这个，切特·阿奇博尔德，如果他存在的话，他只是你的傀儡，他……他或者你写了一个关于西比尔书的问题……那不是我。所以西比尔书是罗马的，它们是这些……好吧，告诉我们西比尔书是什么。嗯，所以西比尔书是我开始写《卢比孔河》时用的，那是我关于罗马共和国衰落的书，所以是的，也许是我，谁知道呢。嗯，西比尔书是……据说是……
sibyls were um women who were had gift of prophecy and a sibyl came to Tarquin, the king of Rome, and she carried nine books of prophecy, books written in Greek, and she offers them for an extortionate price. Tarquin laughs in the face and tells her to go away. She then comes back and offers him six. He does the same thing. She then comes back back offers him three and at this point he's kind of slightly nervous that he might be missing out on something important so he pays gets the sibiline books um chet is asking um do do we think they actually date back to the regal period i i don't know the answer to that i don't think anyone i think it's possible to know but it's certain that the romans thought that they did and that they were very ancient and i think they probably
西比尔是……拥有预言天赋的女性，一位西比尔来到罗马国王塔克文面前，她带着九本预言书，用希腊语写成的书，她以高昂的价格提供给国王。塔克文嘲笑她，叫她走开。然后她回来，提供给他六本。他做了同样的事情。然后她回来，提供给他三本，这时他有点紧张，觉得可能会错过什么重要的东西，所以他付了钱，得到了西比尔书。切特问，我们是否认为它们真的可以追溯到王政时期？我不知道答案，我不认为任何人……我认为不可能知道，但可以肯定的是，罗马人认为它们确实如此，而且它们非常古老，我认为它们可能
were very ancient and the s they probably were very ancient and the sibiline books were um what kind of again it's a bit like in moments of extreme crisis who you're going to ask you know some think tank some specialists some you know people who can guide you i guess our equivalent now would be sage um right it's it you know in moments of extreme crisis you need your specialists and the sibiline books provided kind of divine guidance now it by and large what the sibiline books do is in so far as we can tell from the historical records is not to provide prophecies but to tell you what you have to do if something weird has happened so if some terrible convulsion has occurred some strange
非常古老，西比尔书是……什么样子的？这又有点像在极端危机时刻你会去问谁，你知道，某个智库，某个专家，你知道，能指导你的人。我想我们现在的对应物会是SAGE（科学咨询小组），对吧？在极端危机时刻，你需要你的专家，而西比尔书提供了某种神圣的指导。现在，总的来说，西比尔书的作用，就我们从历史记录中能看出的，并不是提供预言，而是告诉你如果发生了奇怪的事情你必须做什么。所以如果发生了一些可怕的动荡，一些奇怪的
phenomena has happened um portending the anger ofulsion has occurred, some strange phenomena has happened, portending the anger of the gods, you go to the Sibylline books and it tells you what you do to appease the gods. But I think that doesn't necessarily mean that there were no prophecies. It's just that we're not told that. And you do get the sense over the course of Roman history
现象发生了，预示着神的愤怒，你去查阅西比尔书，它会告诉你为了平息神的愤怒你该做什么。但我认为这并不一定意味着没有预言。只是我们没有被告知而已。而且在罗马历史的过程中，你确实会感觉到
that the Sibylline books contain prophecies saying what the fate of the Roman people is going to be. So that's the Sibylline books. Okay, so that's very nice for me. Is there one for, oh, no, here's one for you. Tom of Bedlam. Do you think Oswald Spengler will be proved right? Well, that's not a name you hear very much. So Oswald Spengler is this sort of early 20th century German writer who thinks, his big idea is the decline of the West. So he thinks history is divided into the rise and fall of different civilizations. I can't remember whether it was eight or nine, kind of Babylonian, Roman, Persian, and Western sort of
西比尔书包含着预言，说明罗马人民的命运将会如何。所以这就是西比尔书。好吧，这对我很不错。有没有一个……哦，不，这里有一个给你的。贝德兰的汤姆。你认为奥斯瓦尔德·斯宾格勒会被证明是正确的吗？嗯，那不是一个你经常听到的名字。所以奥斯瓦尔德·斯宾格勒是20世纪初的德国作家，他认为，他的核心思想是西方的衰落。所以他认为历史被划分为不同文明的兴衰。我不记得是八个还是九个，比如巴比伦、罗马、波斯和西方，某种
what you would call Western Christendom is the last one. And he thinks it's doomed and we're living in the sort of end times of our own civilization. And he's writing this after the First World War or before? Yeah, around about the First World War. I think maybe during. My memory of it is kind of hazy. But I think it's clearly against that backdrop. You know, a backdrop where, I mean, actually, we talked about the origins of the First World War before. I've been writing a children's book about the First World War in the last few weeks. And it's just astounding when you think about how that world, that late
你所说的西方基督教世界是最后一个。他认为它注定要灭亡，我们正生活在我们自己文明的末日。他是在第一次世界大战之后还是之前写这本书的？是的，大约在第一次世界大战期间。我想也许是在期间。我的记忆有点模糊。但我认为这显然是在那个背景下。你知道，一个背景，我的意思是，实际上，我们之前谈论过第一次世界大战的起源。过去几周我一直在写一本关于第一次世界大战的儿童书。当你想到那个世界，那个晚期
Victorian world, just collapsed, just disintegrated. So, you know, if you weren't living in Germany or Austria, Hungary or Russia, and you were a sort of middle class, prosperous person, your world has just completely disintegrated. So Spengler was writing against that background. He thought the West was going to go the way of the Incas, that our world was going to be destroyed. And of course, that idea, Spengler has now been rejected. But actually, that idea is still very widespread, isn't it? I mean, you see it now in all the sort of talk of the democratic model has failed, China the future all that sort of stuff he was also i mean so so if he's talking about civilizations yeah that's i mean that's the theme of um huntingdon's book which i think he wrote in
维多利亚时代的世界是如何崩溃、瓦解的，真是令人震惊。所以，你知道，如果你不是生活在德国、奥匈帝国或俄罗斯，而是一个中产阶级、富裕的人，你的世界刚刚完全瓦解了。所以斯宾格勒是在那个背景下写作的。他认为西方会走上印加人的道路，我们的世界会被摧毁。当然，那个想法，斯宾格勒现在已经被拒绝了。但实际上，那个想法仍然非常普遍，不是吗？我的意思是，你现在在所有关于民主模式已经失败、中国是未来等等的讨论中都能看到它。他也是……我的意思是，如果他在谈论文明，是的，我的意思是，那是亨廷顿书的主题，我想他写于
the 90s the classic civilizations which was um and it came out the same time as fukuyama's um yeah end of history and those are the two kind of great prophetic books. Yeah, they're the post-Cold War prophecies of the future, aren't they? I mean, the Clash of Civilizations thesis is, I mean, in a way, it's not been disproved over the... Well, it hasn't been disproved, but I mean, I think it's a very controversial, it's a very controversial topic, isn't it? But the theme of civilizations has come back as part of the kind of geopolitical conversation
90年代，《文明的冲突》，那是……而且它和福山的《历史的终结》同时出版，是的，那是两本伟大的预言书。是的，它们是冷战后对未来的预言，不是吗？我的意思是，文明冲突论，我的意思是，在某种程度上，它并没有被推翻……好吧，它没有被推翻，但我的意思是，我认为这是一个非常有争议的话题，不是吗？但文明的主题已经作为地缘政治对话的一部分回归了
in a way that it wasn't in the 90s. Although what the civilizations are that are clashing has changed. So in the 90s, when Huntington was writing that, I mean, the big fault line was the Balkans. And people at Huntington, American sort of think tankers were sort of saying, there's this huge fault line between Catholicism and Orthodoxy and Islam, and it's all Bosnia and the sort of the dividing line between the Austro-Hungarian and Ottoman empires. Well, now we're not so interested in that, because basically the Balkans is all going to end up in the EU. And actually, even the one that was really interesting for the last 20 years,
以一种90年代所没有的方式。尽管正在冲突的文明是什么已经改变了。所以在90年代，当亨廷顿写那本书时，我的意思是，巨大的断层线是巴尔干半岛。像亨廷顿、美国智库的人都在说，天主教、东正教和伊斯兰教之间存在巨大的断层线，全是波斯尼亚，以及奥匈帝国和奥斯曼帝国之间的分界线。好吧，现在我们对那个不那么感兴趣了，因为基本上巴尔干半岛最终都会加入欧盟。而且实际上，即使是过去20年里真正有趣的一个，
which is Christianity versus Islam, doesn't seem quite as resonant now. Now it's China and the West, isn't it? But there's been quite a lot over the pandemic of the Confucian values of, yeah, exactly, that have enabled Korea and so on to do much better than us. So the idea of civilisations obviously is not going to go away. I mean, the idea of a clash of civilisations. What about Fukuyama, Tom? Do you have Fukuyama, end of history? I mean, he looks a bit of a...
也就是基督教与伊斯兰教的冲突，现在似乎没有那么响亮了。现在是中国和西方，不是吗？但在疫情期间，关于儒家价值观的讨论很多，是的，正是如此，这使得韩国等地比我们做得好得多。所以文明的概念显然不会消失。我的意思是，文明冲突的概念。福山呢，汤姆？你有福山，《历史的终结》吗？我的意思是，他看起来有点……
That thesis is not worn terribly well, shall we say. Well, my hot take on Fukuyama is that he didn't actually predict what people think he did. But because I haven't read it since the 90s I couldn't possibly elaborate on what that is, but I know what the hot take is. I think he thinks he's been maligned, doesn't he? He sort of says he's been
那个论点并没有经受住时间的考验，我们可以这么说。好吧，我对福山的热门观点是，他实际上并没有预测人们认为他预测的事情。但因为我从90年代起就没读过它，我不可能详细说明那是什么，但我知道热门观点是什么。我想他认为自己被诋毁了，不是吗？他某种程度上说他被
grossly maligned, but in a sense he has to say that. Yes, yes. Well, I think that we have looked into the future enough. And, you know, frankly, this is a history podcast, so next time we are going to go definitely back to the past. Dominic, we are going to do our top ten kind of...
严重诋毁了，但在某种意义上他必须这么说。是的，是的。好吧，我认为我们已经对未来看得够多了。而且，坦率地说，这是一个历史播客，所以下次我们肯定会回到过去。多米尼克，我们要列出我们的前十名……
Weird wars is the wrong phrase. Weird wars is the right... No, it's a good phrase. I've got some very weird wars lined up. OK, so I'm choosing five and you're choosing five and we will be um we'll be back with them um thanks so much for all your questions so do look out for uh the next um one coming out on thursday bye for now bye Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
奇怪的战争是错误的说法。奇怪的战争是正确的……不，这是一个很好的说法。我准备了一些非常奇怪的战争。好的，所以我选五个，你选五个，我们将……我们将带着它们回来……非常感谢你们所有的问题，所以请留意下周四发布的下一个……再见。谢谢收听《历史的其余部分》。如需额外剧集、抢先收听、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。